the area around the presidential Palace
and the Army headquarters in Khartoum is
the focus of intense fighting as the
Army and paramilitary group the rapid
support forces battle for control of
Sudan
many of the city's six million residents
are trapped in their homes with power
outages a lack of running water and
dwindling Food Supplies
they're angry that a 72-hour ceasefire
for the Muslim holiday of edel fitter
hasn't held
I want to say to the both side we are
the civilians we are the pain the price
we're not supposed to live in
in this situation we are panicking we
are panicking this we are struggling
this is too much for us
both sides say they're aware of the
impact on the Sudanese people the
commander of the rapid support forces
says he's asked the um for help and has
spoken to Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez about the humanitarian truce
safe passage of residents who want to
leave and the protection of Aid workers
[Applause]
easy to get a clear picture of the
situation
the Army says the rsf attacked a prison
and released many of the inmates but the
rsf denies this and accuses soldiers of
bombing residential areas
what is clear is that the United States
and other countries are preparing for
the evacuation of their citizens and
Embassy staff
we have no higher priority than the
Safety and Security of U.S government
Personnel their dependents and private
U.S citizens abroad and we have made
very clear to both sides that any
attacks threats or dangers posed to our
diplomats are totally unacceptable
but now both sides seem determined to
fight on leaving millions of Sudanese
fearing for their lives Victoria Gayton
B Al Jazeera